so here are eight things that you should
be aware of if you want to become a
millionaire all right so this guy who
gives this advice he's the founder of
something called hubspot are you
familiar with hubspot yeah we use
hubspot we use hubspot here yeah i know
his name is
dharmesh shah dharmesha of course he's
worth about a hundred million no big
deal
and you know he's the founder of hubs he
says look here's eight ideas
do with them what you want here's eight
ideas right all right step one
idea number one
it's a little ironic here right just
down people don't obsess over money i.e
don't focus
solely
on money seems a little counterintuitive
yeah why though he says think less about
making more money yeah and think more
about making your business run smoother
for sure i like this it makes complete
sense how many friends you have out
there i just want to [ __ ] make money
man she's gonna make money but they
don't have an idea they don't have a
business they don't have they don't have
anything they just want the money yeah
the people who really actually move the
needle i'm building a business i have an
idea i'm going to double down on this
i'm going to stop everything i'm doing
and i'm going to focus on this
if they're building a business they're
not just focusing
on the money
it's an idea for you that's number one i
dig it number two
this is this seems obvious
be a helper helping what does that mean
think of business as helping what does
that mean exactly helping customers
helping in your investors helping your
partners helping your employees achieve
what they want help the people around
you
and will benefit you and your business a
lot of people say i just want to make
money man well understand in order to
make money people need to actually feel
like you're helping them accomplish
something okay of course so in my
business i do insurance sales or life
settlement sales yeah i can make money
but i facilitate a deal that actually
benefits the client and i don't get paid
until the client is satisfied
i'm helping the client so that's number
two
is actually help people okay number
three
there's a difference between making and
serving this kind of goes to the second
point right here you know making money
will always be less fruitful than
serving more people it's kind of what we
just talked about you got to serve more
people find a way to reach more people
and the money will come here's an
example
if you focus on how to serve one million
people instead of how to get a million
dollars in revenue think about how much
money you can make serving people
helping people these are his eight steps
right created hubspot okay number four
reinvest in improving your business aka
investing in yourself i say this all the
time the best investment you can make is
where within yourself boom improving
self-improvement getting better getting
faster getting stronger getting richer
getting sexier david
getting sexier
you think that mustache just [ __ ]
found its way onto your face for a
reason you said this is going to be a
good look for me it better be yeah i
know i've heard the stories it's a great
look for you
anyway
investing in your business they say your
comfort zone will kill you you know
you've seen this happens every year
that you know so and so used to be a top
500 company they're no longer on the
list so and so used to be a part of the
s p 500 they're no longer on the list so
and so used to be biz ducky this example
today about how um grubhub used to be
the number one delivery app now it's
doordash because grubhub they got caught
sleeping so the point is that some some
companies some people
get lazy they get stale and they don't
keep up with the times and they end up
losing market share to competitors so
you got to stay sharp you got to stand
around here pbd think that guy's getting
caught sleeping hell no jesus
i got grinds that's step number four
number step number five become the best
in the world
you ready at just
one
thing be known for something
right stand for something or fall for
anything 100 agree with that okay
so be good at one thing be known for one
thing focus on that learn practice and
prove every aspect of that one thing you
become a specialist at that and not a
jack of all trades because you know
what's synonymous with being a jack of
all trades tell me being a jackass i
knew it you knew who's coming man i knew
that [ __ ] was coming it was coming
[ __ ] david i get so freaking frustrated
with you sometimes because you know it's
coming
but you don't meet me there what's roi
again david what's roi return on
investment my guy anyway bro hundred
episodes 100
be good at one thing let me tell you
something i was the king of jack of all
trades in my 20s i was a nightlife guy
and a club promoter and i did stand-up
comedy and i did a little bit of real
estate and i wanted to be a sports agent
i played a little bit of basketball and
i was out partying the clubs i was a
substitute freaking teacher yeah i was
making no money you're one big earnest
series
ernest goes to camp ernest goes to south
beach goes to south beach ernest hits
the club
ernest tells jokes yeah that's that's
what it was and i made no money
so eventually i found myself
at a cold becoming a cold caller for a
financial firm right i knew nothing
about life insurance i certainly didn't
know anything about life insurance
settlements which are basically like
reverse insurance policies where we buy
broker out insurance policies for cash
the point is this i spent a year of my
life
learning training and proving at this
one thing i knew that i was good at
picking up the phones and talking to
people i knew i was not scared i knew
that i said [ __ ] it i'll dial i knew
that
i knew that'd be okay with that i didn't
give a [ __ ] what i was selling i wanted
to sell something i believed in and the
company i believed in but i knew i was
good at sales okay i knew that i could
be good at that i just needed a company
that said focus on this and get good at
this meanwhile 15 years later i'm the vp
of sales of this major financial firm
called welcome funds it's what i do and
i'm not here at valuetainment and we're
the number one leading brokerage in the
country i'm a specialist at this one
thing you think growing up as a kid i
was like i want to be the number one
life settlement broker in the country no
you think when pat was growing up he
wanted to have the top insurance company
in the country no
but in order to work on your passions
you got to make that money yeah right
if you're focusing on money you can
pursue your passions if you're focusing
on just your passion
it's kind of hard to make that money you
got to have both yeah the combination 50
50 50 50. yeah so i focused on getting
good at this one thing made that money
now look at me now working on a passion
anyway get good at one thing david what
do you want to be good known for what's
the one thing uh something in production
absolutely i mean content writing yeah
definitely so i'm focusing on that here
i am but value team there you are little
by little here he is
beautiful man right there anyway when
you focus on this one thing you say all
right cool i got it now
step number six
make a top ten list
why make a top ten list what are you
talking about stop stop make a top ten
list make a list of the top ten people
who are doing the best
at the field you want to be in
make a top 10 list of the best people in
the world at that one thing and see what
they're doing aka don't be a hater be
appreciated so when i wanted to when i
started making money i was like holy
[ __ ] i'm 35 years old i've got money now
i've got i'm a [ __ ] millionaire this
is insane i was broke 10 years ago right
i was worse than broke i was poor
i think poor's worse than broke poor you
got no money you make money and it
sounds poor yeah yeah yeah the point is
this
i made a top 10 list i said who's doing
what i want to be doing i said all right
susie orman she's old school but she's
good
i said all right dave ramsey he's got
some stuff going on he's pretty good i
said robert kiyosaki all right cool
ended up interviewing him ironically he
was on my list right i started going
down this list pbd was on my list
he was a top 10 guy on my list get out i
mean i knew pat but i said he's the guy
when you want to be an entrepreneur
that's the guy yeah i had a i had gary v
on my list i want to say grant cardone
was was up there not that i'm a big cran
cardone guy but these are people that i
thought were doing well
okay
and i made a top 10 list
in this world so that's it make a top 10
list whatever you want to be you want to
be a producer top 10 producers i want to
emulate boom
so after you make this list here's step
number seven step number seven is build
routines around becoming
the best at that one thing so there's a
difference between wishing
and sticking
wishing yeah and sticking
wishing won't get you there but sticking
to a plan and sticking to a routine will
does that make sense total sense of
course okay
you know land of a thousand wishes
not gonna work out for you sticking to a
plan sticking to an agenda that does so
you set your goals right you track your
progress you fix what's not working
you know a lot of people say um
my goal is to just improve and get
better than i was yesterday
bisdox says when he does his stuff
i hope this found you better than i
found i hope this uh i hope i leave you
better hopefully i leave you better than
i found you what a what a powerful
statement yeah
improving
one inch every day proving a little bit
every day one iota every single day
compound interest baby
size routine i do i what do i do
every day
i show gratitude appreciation i do my
stretches i do my yoga i want to build
my health my wealth and my happiness
that's it that's my routine so if i am i
doing the things that are actually
aligning with those things am i doing
unhealthy [ __ ]
dude i haven't had a carb in seven years
bro
just kidding i've had a couple calls but
i try to limit it i don't want to call
you out on the show but
i've seen those chips i've seen those
shows yeah we did have some cheetos last
night anyway
but health health is big for me wealth
having money not so much to buy things
but be able to do things yeah health uh
wealth when you got money it buys you
time hey i need you to do this i'm gonna
need to not want to do this i'm good
yeah exactly okay i'm not saying that i
don't have things to do
but i do as much as i can what i want to
be doing that's it
and then happiness who doesn't want that
so you build these routines you get an
agenda going on and then step number
eight you track your progress how the
[ __ ] am i doing how am i doing
doing all right
now i'm falling behind i've gained 20
pounds i've lost 20 pounds i've built my
wealth by 100 grand i've lost 100 grand
kind of miserable kind of happy how's
wealth happiness those are the things
that i focus on anyway
if you're tracking your progress maybe
you're saying all right what does that
mean for business all right how many
deals have you done how many customers
have you served how many people have you
actually helped we talked about number
two helping being a helper okay
so you track your progress and for an
opportunity arises you can show them the
goods show me the goods show me the
money so anyway those are the eight
steps this guy
basically broke down give me his name
again
darmesh darmesh
hubspot good advice bad advice what do
you think yeah i dig it i mean
ultimately it just
boils down to dude discipline yeah eight
steps we have to like you said check on
them and continue until you get to that
because you can do these eight steps but
if you have zero discipline yeah it's
all for not i get it i thank you for
everything you're listening i see uh my
guy paul brown tell me to smash the like
button thank you if you haven't
subscribed to valuetainment economics
it's a separate channel from our
from our mothership valuetainment yeah
subscribe to valuetainment economics
this is what we do we talk money
and give that smash give that like
button a smash anyway you're doing these
eight things something tells me if
you're actually doing these eight things
the money's going to come yeah
completely with discipline
i like that top 10 list thing i like
that top ten list thing is that your
favorite step no i think get become the
best in the world that one thing is is
key yeah especially warren buffen says
that there's certain ways um that you be
can become recession-proof or
inflation-proof yeah get good at one
thing absolutely you never hear people
who are the best of the best be like oh
inflation they're not worried about it
yeah anyway
so when you track your progress and you
keep your stats that's all help that'll
help you um
when new opportunities arise
[Music]
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broke
[Music]